Imagine a farmer
growing coffee in Nkongsamba,
in the Moungo region of Cameroon.
Let’s call him Mr. Ewané.
Mr. Ewané lives
out of a small plot of land,
growing food to feed his family,
and coffee, to earn a very modest income.
While many of us in the Western world
debate about climate change,
Mr. Ewané knows it is real.
The rainy season is becoming more erratic,
impacting his coffee production
that has been declining year after year.
Mister [unclear] is by no means
responsible for climate change.
His own CO2 emissions
are below 200 kilograms per year,
while we in the developed world
emit 30 to 60 times more than he does.
Our way of living -- his problem.
The great story is that Mister [unclear]
can improve his standard of living
while removing CO2 from the atmosphere
and helping fight climate change.
This is not about trees.
It's much smaller.
Sounds interesting?
Well, bear with me.
In order to fight climate change,
we need to reduce, like crazy,
our greenhouse-gas emissions,
halving, in the next 10 years,
the 50 billion tonnes
that we emit annually,
and then aiming to halve again
in the following decade.
While reduction is needed,
it will not be enough
to get us to zero emissions,
[which] is needed to stabilize climate.
There will be, for a very long time,
residual emissions,
from some industrial processes,
from aviation, from agriculture, etc.
Billions of tonnes of residual emissions,
even when we have reduced all that we can.
So we can't be zero emissions,
but we can be net-zero emissions:
that is, removing from the atmosphere,
as much CO2 as we emit annually.
And maybe, one day,
remove more than we emit,
to restore our climate balance.
That's when Mister [unclear]
comes into play.
He has been capturing CO2
through the growth of his crops,
year after year.
Photosynthesis that drives
the growth of crops
is by far the most efficient way
to capture CO2 from the atmosphere.
But if nothing is done,
that same CO2 goes straight back
into the atmosphere
when plants decompose or are burned.
But the good news
is that we can stabilize the carbon
contained in the leftovers
from the coffee cherries
of Mister [unclear].
That means we can remove
CO2 year after year
and help fight climate change.
And what if that same technology
would allow Mister [unclear] to improve
the productivity of his fields,
hence his standard of living?
Now you start to see the opportunity.
It’s called “biochar.”
Let me say right away that biochar
is by no means a magic wand
that will take us
out of the climate crisis.
It's one of the many solutions
to help remove CO2 from the atmosphere.
But if used smartly,
it's just an amazing thing.
Biochar is carbon
resulting from pyrolysis,
that is, heating biomass
at high temperature without oxygen.
Any kind of plant-based, dried biomass
contains about half of its weight
in the form of carbon.
And it is this carbon
that is extracted and stabilized
to create biochar.
Biochar is essentially carbon
that was captured
from the atmosphere by plants
and transformed
into a very stable form of carbon.
It looks like charcoal powder.
The first amazing property of biochar
is that it remains stable
for hundreds of years,
even if put in the soil,
where biomass will normally degrade.
Think about it.
The CO2 captured by plants
through photosynthesis
and converted into biochar
stays in the soil, and so stays away
from the atmosphere,
for hundreds of years.
So we have a carbon removal situation,
and this is good for the climate.
The second amazing property of biochar
is that, when mixed with topsoil,
it improves the soil quality,
hence, crop yields.
This is especially true for poor,
dry and acidic soils that lack nutrients.
Putting carbon in the soil
has been known empirically
for hundreds of years
as a way to improve soil quality.
It was used in some parts of Amazonia
prior to the arrival of Europeans,
and it's still used today
in some parts of Asia.
Biochar's effects on soil
come from its microstructure.
When magnified, biochar
looks like a carbon sponge,
with hundreds of square meters of surface
per gram of biochar.
This ultraporous structure
helps retain water and nutrients.
Biochar also favors the development
of microbial life into the soil
that is most needed for plants
to absorb nutrients.
And last, given its high pH,
biochar helps counter
the negative effects of soil acidity.
Using biochar allows to reduce,
or even eliminate,
the need for fertilizers,
cutting costs for farmers
and helping the environment.
And the great thing is that,
given its stability,
biochar needs to be applied just once,
and its effects last for decades.
And then, there's a bonus.
The production process of biochar
generates flammable gases.
Part of those gases
are used to heat the reactor
where biochar is produced,
and the remaining gases can be used
to generate renewable heat or electricity.
So not only the production
process of biochar
is self-sustained,
but it is a source
of additional renewable energy.
Quite incredible.
So we have this amazing product
that is a climate solution,
an agricultural solution
and a renewable energy solution.
And now, you start to wonder:
"How come this biochar thing
that he's talking about
is not widely used all over the place?
What's the problem?"
Well, the answer is plain and simple:
costs.
Most biochar produced in the last years
had to be sold at prices as high
as 1,000 dollars per tonne,
to cover production costs.
That made biochar uneconomical
for most usages.
And so, despite its wonderful properties,
it has remained a niche product.
But things started to change
in the last couple of years.
The recognition of climate change
started to shift our behaviors,
leading companies and states
to commit to net-zero trajectories.
Some innovative companies
committed to an accelerated
net-zero trajectory;
started to buy, at a high price,
biochar-based carbon credits
for their long-term CO2 removal effects.
That changed the economics of biochar,
as all of a sudden,
the climate benefits of biochar
could help subsidize
its agricultural usage.
As a consequence,
biochar is emerging
as a credible CO2 removal solution,
especially that it is one of the very few
that are available today for scaling.
The technology is mature.
The scientific backing is here.
The economics could work.
And the potential is huge.
In Africa alone,
we estimate that half a billion tonnes
of agricultural residues
are available to produce biochar.
That means about the same amount of CO2
being removed every year
from the atmosphere,
and there are many more billion tonnes
in the rest of the world.
So let's make biochar a solution at scale.
For this, we need three things.
One, access to biomass.
Biochar production requires
a large quantity of dry biomass,
ideally sourced close
to the production facilities
to avoid transportation costs
and emissions.
It needs to be residual biomass
so it does not require
additional land to grow it.
Most biochar companies today
use wood residues,
like sawdust or branches,
to produce biochar.
But many alternatives exists --
in particular, agricultural residues.
Two, we need superefficient,
24-7 production systems.
The technology exists,
but there's still room for improvement.
And three,
we need to encourage farmers
to use biochar
so that they can reduce
the usage of fertilizers,
and improve crop yields.
Many companies, as we speak,
are developing biochar-based business
in a variety of geographies
and with a variety of feedstocks.
I cofounded one of them.
We focus on tropical developing countries.
Biomass is superabundant there,
in the form of agricultural residues.
We used an optimized production model,
with easy-to-operate,
midsize production plants,
where the pyrolysis reactor
looks like a tank wagon.
Soils in the tropics
are generally poor and acidic,
hence benefit the most
from the addition of biochar.
And last,
energy generation is most needed
in rural areas of developing countries,
where, very often,
less than 25 percent of the people
have access to electricity.
That's how we go back to Mister [unclear].
We will convert to biochar
the leftovers from his coffee cherries
so that he can use it in his fields
to improve the quantity
and quality of his production.
Mr. Ewané will be able
to afford the biochar,
given that it will be highly subsidized
by the related carbon credits.
And the electricity generated
will be distributed locally.
A very circular model,
for climate and people,
now.
Thank you for your attention.